José El Elegido para formar el próximo
gobierno de Israel así lo confirmó el
presidente israelí Isaac herzog tras el
cierre de las conversaciones formales
con los partidos que van a integrar el
próximo parlamento esta asignación va a
quedar oficializada el domingo tras un
nuevo encuentro entre gersor y netanya
quien luego tendrá 28 días para formar
un gobierno que le permita volver a ser
Primer Ministro por tercera vez de estas
conversaciones se comprobó lo que ya se
sabía que netanías Justine el apoyo de
64 parlamentarios los de su partido
licut los de la sede tres facciones que
integraron la alianza de extrema derecha
sionismo religioso en las elecciones y
los de los dos partidos Ultra ortodoxos
de esta Alianza se espera que surja un
gobierno que ya empieza a despertar
preocupaciones por las enviadas racistas
homófobas y antiárabes y radicales de
derecha que han mostrado algunos de sus
integrantes gerso que en las
conversaciones con los partidos expresó
estas Preocupaciones en particular en
una reunión con el parlamentario vivir a
quien le dijo que el mundo está
preocupado por su inclusión en el
próximo gobierno aunque él intentó
enviar un mensaje de moderación no ayudó
que se lo viera en el Memorial del
rabino fundador del partido en el que
ven vivir se formó políticamente Espero
que fue declarado terrorista en su
momento por Estados Unidos y por Israel
también expresó sus preocupaciones
gersor al partido Ultra religioso en
noam que en el pasado ha tenido
declaraciones contra la comunidad lgbt
el presidente pidió que se respete a
todas las personas por igual estas
advertencias marcan la incertidumbre
hacia la que se dirige Israel con este
este gobierno más radical hacia la
derecha y la duda es sin atañejo tendrá
la capacidad de moderar las posturas más
radicales de sus aliados políticos